[Musique]
faut-il instaurer un dividende pour les
employeurs un titre que pour les
actionnaires oui il va nous dire
Thibault donc ça de bonjour bonjour
président de Luminess et président de
l'URSSAF c'est comme ça qu'on vous
appelle le théoricien donc du ce
dividende salarié Emmanuel Macron
l'avait on a fait une promesse de
campagne on s'en souvient le
gouvernement là dans ces cartons donc ça
veut dire que tout entreprises je résume
un petit peu qui versera qui verserait
des dividendes devra aussi en même temps
verser ce dividende salarié tout ça
inscrit dans la loi c'est un peu résumé
mais c'est ça l'idée c'est un peu ça
mais on va partir d'un dispositif qui
est déjà existant qui est la
participation votre dispositif c'est ce
qui est important c'est de dire que sous
la bannière dividende et je vais y
revenir pourquoi j'ai appelé ça le
dividende salarié on part d'un
dispositif existant qui date des années
77 des ordonnances de 67 voulues par le
général de Gaulle qui est de faire en
sorte qu'il y a un meilleur partage de
la valeur et donc il faut
c'était déjà contrasté je pense que plus
de 50 ans après il faut revoir ce
dispositif parce que le partage de la
valeur est un acte de réconciliation que
nous devons avoir avec les salariés les
actionnaires je pense qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est très simple c'est que
regarder on est probablement le seul
pays au monde en tout cas en Europe où
chaque fois qu'on verse des dividendes
et qu'on les dividendes sont importants
on crie oh là là c'est disproportionné
c'est trop important voire même c'est
une spoliation qui est fait sur le dos
de l'entreprise du salarié il y a pas un
pays où globalement ça se passe mal
qu'on trouve vers des dividendes qui est
quand même signe de vitalité de notre
économie ce dividendes salariés plutôt
que de parler en tout cas de dividendes
salariés pourquoi est-ce que on pourrait
pas juste dire la participation et ben
on double son montant on a une formule
de calcul plus intéressante plus
avantageuse pour pour le salarié et en
étant à tous les salariés notamment aux
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés pour
aujourd'hui c'est facultatif moi ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est arrêtons-nous
une minute sur le dividende salarié et
j'invite tous les spectateurs à regarder
dans le code du travail alors qui est un
peu épais le chapitre 3 du Code du
travail et on découvre dans le chapitre
3 du Code du travail que les instruments
d'intéressement et de participation se
nomme dividende travail et quand j'ai
essayé de théoriser ce dividende salarié
ce meilleur partage de la valeur
partirou il y avait la prime dite Macron
qui est devenu prime partage de la
valeur un troisième dispositif qui s'est
on va dire avancer et bien je me suis
dit finalement il faut renommer ça du
dividende cela et le dividende salarié
c'est chaque entreprise qui verse des
dividendes doit verser de la
participation c'est ça le thème mais
aujourd'hui toute boîte qui fait des
bénéfices de plus 50 salariés doit
verser une participation alors oui mais
vous avez des entreprises qui versent
pas de participation parce qu'elles sont
organisées de telle façon
contenu de la formule de participation
qui ne verse pas de participation et
donc il faut regarder un contournement
il y a une forme de contournement
d'optimisation et puis vous l'avez dit
justement vous avez 150000 entreprises
on va dire de PME vous avez des moyennes
PME des grosses PME ça fait un peu près
10 millions de salariés et sur ces 10
millions de salariés vous avez que 2
millions 3 qui sont couverts par un
dispositif d'intéressement et de
participation donc 50% des salariés du
privé exactement
ce qui revient à peu près à ça ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut probablement rendre
ce dispositif accessible à l'ensemble
des entreprises à l'exception des moins
de 11 où là la prime partage de la
valeur peut fonctionner parce que il
faut la simplicité mais oui dans les PME
dans les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire il faut que l'on puisse
mettre en place de la participation ce
dividende salarié il pourrait
représenter combien de mois de salaire
je sais pas si on peut dire la question
comme ça alors aujourd'hui si on regarde
les masses
intéressement plus participation ça
représente à peu près 20 milliards
on va dire
redistribuer aux salariés si on regarde
la participation c'est globalement 11
milliards
et par montant unitaire par salarié mais
ce qui veut pas forcément dire
grand-chose parce que là on fait une
division c'est un montant qui va à peu
près de 2000 à 3000 euros selon la
taille de l'entreprise alors évidemment
des petites entreprises qui vont donner
500 mais ça peut représenter globalement
c'est ça l'idée en renforçant le
mécanisme de la participation un mois à
13ième ou 14e mois parce que ce que je
propose dans le dividende salarié c'est
plusieurs choses c'est un c'est de
doubler le montant la participation pour
les grandes entreprises le rendre on va
dire systématique dans les entreprises
de moins de 50 et puis de mettre en
place une formule de participation pour
les PME qui soit plus audible et plus
accessible la participation c'est pas
déjà une forme de dividende du travail
puisque on sait qu'elle est assise sur
le bénéfice de l'entreprise ils avaient
raison c'est au plus près du dividende
donc c'est déjà une cote part du
dividende donc voilà mais je le
réexplique dans la théorie du dividende
salarié d'ailleurs voilà c'est contrasté
le patronat aura sa vision les syndicats
par la visio en parler donc je le
réhabilite d'une certaine façon mais oui
vous avez raison la formule de
participation si je la donne là je pense
que tout le monde va se coucher
à juste titre il faut la simplifier mais
elle est déjà une quote-part du
dividende
cet ancien numéro 2 du Medef Thibault
langsad le patronat n'est pas fan et
vous le savez de votre dividende salarié
pour le patronat ça augmente le coût du
travail et sa nuit à la compétitivité
ce dividende salarié j'ai envie de dire
oui et non ça augmente
ce sont des dispositifs qui sont on va
dire souvent dénuées de fiscalité de
quoi c'est ce qu'on appelle le
forcercial pour les grandes entreprises
il est inexistant pour les entreprises
de moins de 250 salariés sur
l'intéressement et inexistant sur la
participation pour les moins de 50
salariés donc ce sont des dispositifs
qui peuvent être gagnants gagnants mais
le vrai sujet c'est la réconciliation un
meilleur partage de la valeur et ça
c'est une aspiration que nous voulons
tous et donc parce qu'il y a un problème
de partage de la valeur en France oui un
sujet sur le partage de la valeur les
primes la participation l'intéressement
l'épargne salariale mais au global il y
a un problème de partage je pense que on
a besoin davantage de sens et de être
mieux associé à la performance de l'onde
ça veut dire qu'on prend à qui on prend
l'investissement on prend aux dividendes
aux actionnaires pas qu'il faut il
faille le raisonner comme ça je pense
que la nécessité c'est d'avoir des
investissements qui permettent le gâteau
n'est pas infini non mais il faut aussi
avoir des instruments qui permettent
d'avoir une répartition légèrement plus
équitable quand l'entreprise sur
performe c'est le sujet que nous avons
aujourd'hui je dis pas que quand une
entreprise est en difficulté elle peut
pas verser de dividendes elle va pas
d'intéressement de participation mais
quand vous avez des résultats
exceptionnels c'est quand même le cas de
nos entreprises et une fois de plus
c'est à la gloire de notre industrie
c'est à la gloire de notre économie tant
mieux ça nous permet d'avoir un chômage
en diminution de verser une contribution
on va dire fiscale plus importante en
2022 qui permettra à l'état de mieux
équilibrer son budget donc on a une
contribution mais quand on a des
résultats importants d'avoir un meilleur
partage de la valeur 53 après on voit
les dispositifs intéressants de
participation je pense que ça vaut le
coup allez merci beaucoup Thibault lança
donc président de lumineux c'est
président de l'URSSAF merci merci
[Musique]